hi my name is amy mathers
um i am a associate professor of
medicine and pathology
at university of virginia and um
i work in both the clinical micro lab
and in the infectious disease division
doing
epidemiology antibiotic stewardship and
um
and then focus on clinical micro um
so i'm going to just tell you a little
bit of a story about
um how um
we tried to solve a problem in our
hospital
with um antibiotic resistance and
tracking genes of drug resistance and
what that
showed us about how important it is to
use various sequencing techniques to to
track
um genes of drug resistance as they move
through bacterial populations on mobile
genetic elements
um and so hopefully that'll be of
interest to
several of you so the objectives today
are to
understand the primary mechanisms of
horizontal gene transfer
between strains and species and then i'm
going to go through
why um horizontal gene transfers
is an important concept to understand
because it is probably the mechanism for
moving around some of the most
significant genes of drug resistance
that we're facing today
in the antimicrobial resistance crisis
and then to really understand why
both long read and short read and the
differences in the roles and
understanding the genetic context for
horizontal gene transfer
so pretty much everything i'm going to
talk about
has to do with a single gene of drug
resistance
so kpc so the number one cause of
carbopenum resistance in the united
states is driven by
this gene klebsiella and ammonia
carbopenomas
it's poorly named because as you'll see
here in the next slide it can move from
species to species
shown in the smaller map there is all
the countries where kpc producers are
endemic
and then where there's sporadic spread
but basically there's been
a global dissemination of kpc producing
bacteria
so what's important background to
understand about kpc
is that this is a gene of drug
resistance
that the enzyme that it makes
can then cause hydrolysis of some of the
most important antibiotics we use to
treat people with infections so
all the penicillins cephalosporins as
treonam and carbapenums
and if you do any clinical medicine you
know that that is
pretty much the backbone of how we
manage serious infections
um in gram negatives in this country or
around the world
and so um losing that efficacy is really
important
there are several novel um inhibitors
for this enzyme and those have come to
market in the last five years
and so that's really helped our ability
to treat and manage infections
when organisms carry the kpc it's seen
pretty much in enterobacter aca
or anaerobacter alice and as you'll see
we've seen it across multiple species
but it's not just confined to that
family of bacteria importantly for this
talk
it's carried on a transposon which is a
10kb
element um that is freely mobile
within a cell and and we'll get into
that
but most descriptions of the kpc gene
have it in this tn-4401 element which
has been consistent
consistently 10 kb long
so we have to go back over a decade to
talk about our first kpc case
we're pretty confident we didn't have
any of these um
prior to this case coming into our
hospital we've done a dig back before
that time
and so we think we know when we had it
and so that's sort of
important to this story because what
then unfolds
is a lot of different species and and
trying to track
where kpc was coming from and getting to
patients in the hospital
the patient who brought it to our
hospital carried both a club pneumonia
club oxytoca that harbored kpc
and this is a picture of the first
almost decade
of our kpc transmission so all the
organisms in this
epidemiologic curve carry kpc you can
see there back in 2007 in august
we had our index patient and what's
unique about this
is that this epidemiologic curve
demonstrates sustained
transmission in a hospital so sort of
endemicity if you will
but what's unique about it is most of
the time when you have an outbreak it's
a single species seen over and over and
over again and in some ways
that's a potential definition of an
outbreak but we were seeing kpc popping
up in all sorts of species even though
we hadn't seen it
prior to this to 2007. it's important to
note that in 2009 we began perirectal
surveillance because we couldn't
understand how
casey was being transmitted between
patients
and so um derrick crook from the
university of oxford saw this
epidemiologic curve saw this kind of
interesting scientific question
and um invited me to do a sabbatical
university of oxford
for a period of time and we sequenced a
lot of these because we thought we
were looking at a plasmid-mediated
outbreak
and so we took all these isolates and
um sequenced all of them and i'll get
into some of the details of that
important to understand what perirectal
surveillance is for those who might not
know
it means you take a swab because most
anaerobacter alice are harbored in the
gut
of a human taking a perirectal swab
swabbing the rectum putting that in
broth then selecting for that organism
um we do a broth selection and if
something grows in that
um with an antibiotic disc with a
carbopenem disc
um we then plate it to a chrome auger
and then we check for
the presence of a carbopetamase by a
phenotypic test
and then we do pcr for all of these so
what i'm going to show you for the
patient data going forward is a mix
between
um carriage or silent carriage
and infections um by kpc producing
organisms
so setting that stage basically i'm
going to talk about
what we discovered through whole genome
sequencing of the first five years of
our outbreak
so in that time period we had 204
patients
we were able to sequence and recover
isolates from 181 of them
this was across 13 species and like i
said we have both clinical and
surveillance specimens
and we were trying to understand how is
kpc spreading
so typically when you have an outbreak
in a hospital
um it's through binary fission you have
a staph aureus outbreak in your hospital
it is the same strain meaning that
the chromosome you know through binary
fission and cell division
that strain is in a human
and then goes to the next human same
exact
strain same clone and in some ways
that's somewhat the definition of an
outbreak
and so we knew that this was not going
to be the primary mechanism
by which transmission was occurring but
could we ask the question from the whole
genome sequencing
of all the clever pneumo that we were
seeing in the hospital was this the way
they were being transmitted
and so in a perfect world you use this
type of data to infer
transmission and so shown here is
what's in an x an index case and then
here's the five year period
uh where we looked at isolates and each
circle
is and and across this would be
an idea of the same chromosome so the
identical strain
by whole genome sequencing and what you
find
is that you'll have a patient on the
wards you've got your index case and
then you've got a patient on the ward
that then picks up the same
strain and they're on the ward and then
the next patient picks up a strain and
the next patient
and so all these solid circles represent
patients who had ward overlap and time
overlap
so patient a was on the ward at the same
time
carrying that strain and then patient b
pops up with the stream strain and they
were on the ward at the same time
with a pretty plausible explanation that
patient a
harbored it initially was the reservoir
and then it got transmitted
usually by the hands of healthcare
workers to patient b
for anybody who does outbreak
determination you know that there's
patients where there's no
ward contact there was no patient to
patient overlap
and this is what our outbreak looked
like so each different color
is a different species and what you'll
note
is that 70 of our outbreak was hollow
circles
so the patient didn't have any ward
contact with any other patient that had
the same
strain and so definitely not a clonal
outbreak there was a strain circulating
in the united states
that had um of club pneumo
or is still circulating in the united
states but a lot of those patients
indicated here by imported meaning they
had it on admission
by exes here we did have some
overlap and potentially some plausible
transmission here of this anaerobacter
strain
but a lot of no ward contact
i'll also highlight that we had these
huge gaps in time between seeing a
strain so you'd see a strain here and
then it'd be two years later you'd see
the same strain in a different patient
as though we had another reservoir
so we knew that this was not the primary
mechanism to spread we kind of knew that
because
we had a multi-species outbreak
so we assumed that what was happening
was plasmid transmission so
for those you know who think about this
stuff a lot you know plasmids are the
little bits of dna much smaller than the
chromosome usually anywhere from
5 to 300
kilobases in size
it means that they have an ability to
replicate within the cell and so
we were thinking that if this is the kpc
gene we knew it was on a transposon
and we knew most of those transposons
were on plasmids
and it was moving between all these
different species so we thought we had a
plasmid-mediated outbreak
early in our journey we went ahead and
sequenced
through a combination of long and short
read
the index patients plasmids because we
figured okay so this patient has
brought it into the hospital it's
probably one of those clebnew or club
oxytocoplasmics that's been transmitted
down the line and so this
plasmid shown here which we dumped pkbc
uva01
was completely novel except for
this bit here that we'll get into but
the transposon
and then it was sandwiched in another
transposon but the rest
of the stock had never been seen in ncbi
at that time
and that was from our index patients
club pneumo
so we had a hunch um partly from just
some molecular
uh work that i'd done early on in some
southern plotting that puv801
was the plasmid transmitting kpc to all
these different species
and throughout our outbreak so
um when i paired up with uh
derek crooks group at oxford anna
shepard
um who is a very gifted bioinformaticist
um was the person that i collaborated
with on this project
and so she thought this was a very
interesting problem
and was very curious just to see if
whether or not we could
solve is it a plasma media outbreak by
looking at short read sequencing
and so again what we what we did was
generate you know plasmid specific
references
from the index patient and then look
um by mapping in to see if that plasmid
was present across the outbreak and with
using a definition of 99
sequence identity over 80 percent of the
reference length um
we kind of ran this across the entire
281 isolates
and here is a here are the phylogenetic
trees of all the different species
and shown here you can see sort of this
is our enterobacter for example a lot of
different
strains as you saw in the previous
picture
and anywhere there's a red dot pova1 was
in that isolate
and so you can see here we have a lot of
red dots
interestingly the blue dot was
the pain the index patient's other
plasmid
so that club oxytocoplasm is shown here
in club oxychocal but also we
we were able to map that plasmid into
some club pneumo into some citrobacter
so it really did look like from our
index
patient pova01 and pvo2 were widely
dispersed among species and strains
we figured it out it is a plasma
mediated outbreak
and again this was all from short read
sequencing but anna shepard
said you know hold on you can't say that
because
you don't know if the plasmid is
contiguous
with the transposon because there's
redundancy around mobile genetic
elements you cannot
necessarily put them into the genetic
context with short read sequencing
because when you do the de novo
assemblies anytime there's redundancy
it's going to break that fragment into a
different contig
so without doing a lot more molecular
work from short read sequencing you
cannot
put them in the genetic context but i
was like well the plasmid's there
clearly so
but to solve this debate
we did um 17 randomly chosen isolates
for pac bio or long read sequencing
and then paired this with the short read
sequencing to get
closed genomic structures
and what did we find we found that
maybe it wasn't a plasma mediated
outbreak
so shown here is the index plasmid pvo1
and then shown here is all the places
where of the 17 11 of them had
what we thought was pvo1 but a lot of
those
that we had assumed that had pva one
actually lost the kpc
gene and so these guys still have pvo1
with kpc
this one has now paired with another
plasmid so it has kp you know the kpc
gene or the transposon that carries it
twice
the rest of these um very few changes
but
i don't know maybe it's not a kpc
plasmid outbreak it has the plasmid but
it doesn't have kpc
and in fact what we found was of the 17
there were 11 different
kpc plasmids across these isolates
all of them were harbored in tn-4401 or
that 10kb transposon
that had been described previously by
nasa's group
so maybe it wasn't a plasmid-mediated
outbreak
and it was the transposon that was
moving around
and so that in fact was was what we
found
in the majority of isolates that we had
the 10kb transposon shown here
tn4401 was actually sandwiched
in another transposon called tn2
and we believe that this caused some
hypermobility
and so to kind of put this into a
pictorial
we have the kpc gene sandwiched in a
transposon
located in another transposon we saw
evidence of
the transposon itself moving from plasma
to plasmid
we saw evidence of the transposon within
the transposon
moving in between other
elements likely through homologous
recombination because this tn2 is
littered
throughout enterobacter aca
plasmid dna and so it was able to
move quite frequently and then we did
see evidence of pvo1
moving in between different species and
strains
and this is an old paper but i thought
it's such a
cool thing that this group took
all the sequences at that time that were
uploaded
um and coded for a protein
and just did a word finding for a
protein finding function
of all microbial organisms on the planet
that had
sequence entered and what they found
is that it wasn't something for
gathering energy
it wasn't something for um any other
purpose
the most common gene sequences are
transpose aces
in nature among our microbial colleague
or
microbial brethren i guess
and so i think that um you know
bacteria are fit to evolve and the fact
that
these genes of drug resistance are now
so
linked to mobile genetic elements and
transpose aces we're going to just see
more and more dissemination and this is
going
understanding this movement is going to
be critical to
understanding how antibiotic resistance
is evolving and emerging
so um back to what was happening in the
hospital
so we had this ongoing you know
multi-species outbreak well
and at the time we didn't have very good
antibiotics and now we've got better
antibiotics for treating kpc producing
organisms but at the time we didn't so
we instituted the peri rectal
surveillance program to try to find
those reservoirs of patients who were
harboring kpc
silently and then isolate them put them
on contact precautions do all sorts of
things so that you wouldn't transmit to
the next patient because we figured that
it was being transmitted on the hands of
healthcare workers
and you know when we instituted that
actually it worked
we saw less transmission
but it didn't ever completely go away
then we started seeing an organism
carrying kpc called aeromonas
and this is not an enterobacterialis but
it is a water
organism and it doesn't have any
business having kpc
and so i was like oh no
this outbreak is in the water and in
fact when we looked
for kpc in sync trades we looked
originally in municipal water and found
nothing
but we started looking in the sink
drains and in the premise plumbing
wastewater
we found a lot of kpc
so this is a picture there of the
counter around the sink which is less
than ideal
um and we believe for a whole bunch of
other data that i'm not going to present
today
that kpc was getting from the drain to
patient care items surrounding the sink
and then that was being transmitted to
patients
drains are probably a problem for um
you know the evolution of bacterial
resistance especially in
anterobacterialis or other gram
negatives
because those gram negatives are quite
durable and happy living in
in low nutrient environments such as a
drain
um and again just to be clear what i'm
talking about is all the colored part
not the water that's coming in from the
community
but drain all the way through to the
exit of the building so the wastewater
side of things
and now that we understand this and this
is more widely understood
um than it was when we sort of came
across it
drains make really great places for
bacteria to
[Music]
sit and evolve and it's because
you know you're seeding drug-resistant
pathogens into a sink because that's
where hospitalized patients have
some of the most antibiotic resistant
organisms going
and so then you give them water which is
always good for life
then selective pressure um goes into the
waste water so wastewater is all
connected in the building
and um just remembering that a lot of
antibiotics don't actually get very
broken down before they go out into
urine
so that selective pressure is added and
then we dispose of nutrients and you've
got an inaccessible biofilm and these
bacteria are allowed to flourish and so
in my mind i was like well these
that's where all the the movement is
happening and that's part of why we're
seeing so much gene mobility in our
hospital it's because we seeded our
waste water
and um you know
that's why puva 1 is done so well
so but again back to the fact that i'm a
physician and epidemiologist we needed
to eliminate the
the transmission and so we put in place
a whole bunch of
um ways to try to keep this from getting
from that drain to the patient so
the obvious thing to do is to get things
away from the sink and so
we still to the stay audit and
make sure that nurses and other health
care providers are not putting things
next to the sink
and we redesigned the room to put things
high up above and then we removed all
the drains thinking we would eliminate
it that way
and then we started pouring bleach and
hydrogen peroxide and i've got a picture
there of
ozone impregnated water to eliminate
that bacteria in the brain
so after i removed them i was like well
done
all all done but what we didn't do was
keep
patients who harbored kpc producing
organisms from coming back to the unit
after we'd removed all the drains
and so this is an example of where if
you don't
do long read sequencing you can't see
some of these
events so there was a patient who
harbored a
kpc serratia um and
after we removed all the drains removed
all those things we were pouring bleach
down to keep it from coming back
um removed all the traps
this patient came back to unit and what
happened was
he had a serratian marcescence and a
klebsiella quasi
when we looked in the drain of that
patient's room
10 days after we'd removed the drain and
readmitted that patient this is the
organism we found
and again without long read sequencing
we never would have been able to see
this event
but what we could see in that drain is
that this patient had a serratia plasmid
kpc plasmids are colored in this and
had this quasi pneumonia all of these
from long read sequencing
and in the drain what we found was the
quasi and ammonium plasmid had actually
taken up the serration plasmid in
addition the transposon had moved
from this other plasma that was in the
original quasi pneumoniae
into the purple background and now this
patient had three
kpc producing plasmids from short read
sequencing you would never be able to
see this type of movement or resolution
i think it's really important to
understand that some organisms seem
fit to take up drug resistance plasmids
well the downside of this whole story is
that the patient
the patient's seratia was then seen
in multiple patients and in multiple
sinks shortly after we eliminate we
removed all the sinks
and we started putting bleach down so we
stopped
realizing that that was not going to be
a solution
after we had a highly clonal outbreak
again this is
the scale here is one snip and these are
all the exact same clone of serratia
seen in multiple patients um shown in
red and um environmental
shown in black
so um in a different talk at another
time i can tell the rest of
that story we continue we have
largely fixed our kpc transmission from
the environment but not completely
eliminated it from the environment
because it's very difficult to do
having said that i kind of wanted to get
back to that idea of
are these organisms evolving and
exchanging plasmids in the drain and
that's where
things are happening so we asked that
question and through cdc funding
we were able to take a deep dive into
some persistently colonized drains
so we used two rooms from two medical
icus
very similar patient population one of
the rooms had a
both a a bathroom sink and a a
patient sink shown there in sort of
picture a
and the other room type had just the one
sink
in the room with the patient and
we wanted to look at a long period of
time of colonization with both
long and short read sequencing to
understand how much plasmid
how much transposon and how much strain
variability do you see if you sequence
every single isolate from that
longitudinal
period so
um we ended up doing about 120
isolates by a long read sequencing we
found
17 strains 12 species
and shown here in this is the different
rooms
as you can see here so at the top kind
of
bar there is room three one two eight
and then the bathroom
in sync in three one two eight and then
down below again
the room the bathroom sink and then uh
below that
is room b type uh three one eight two
and three one nine four
the way we've um done this is we took
all the isolates we had to short read
and long read sequences
we took the chromosome mapped it to a
reference and compared them
and so each strain or each clade
gets a different shape and so we color
coded them by species shown there
on the bottom and then the strains are
shown with different shapes
so what you can see is is there's a lot
of different
strains and species across these sinks
but what i was really trying to get at
was
what about the plasmids so just
interestingly
what's shown here and one of the
surprising things is there was a lot of
chromosomal
integration of kpc and so shown on the
left panel
is all the places where the kpc gene
and transposon had integrated into the
chromosome
there on the right hand side of the
slide
is all the plasmids
but what we found taking and just
going back to this slide you can see
there's the most kind of strain
diversity
among citrobacter so taking a deep dive
into the citrobacter across
all these different rooms um kind of
annotated their
room and sink location and whatnot
we took all the long read sequences of
the plasmids from these different
citrobacter and what you find
is if there is a square around it it
contains the kpc
gene so again kind of going across
here's the phylogenetic tree of the
plasmid
um shown on the left hand side with
those different shapes
that were noted on the previous slides
the metadata there
for which room it was and then
if it was integrated into the chromosome
there it showed in the in the red
squares but again there's puva o1
across all these different clades of
citrobacter
carrying the kpc gene whereas before
we'd seen that the kpc gene
often had moved out of pova1 as a
background
but what we also see is that um
pvo1 or the the kpc gene is actually in
multiple plasmid backgrounds
in different clades as well
um the pac-man-like shapes are where we
couldn't complete or close the the
plasmid structure and so sort of just to
summarize that data
really this this plasmid puv801 sort of
shown there at the very top of the
square
had the most kpc across the most strains
and species
there was a little bit more sharing of
some ink ends
um across some strains and species but
for the for the most part
the plasmid that was shared amongst all
of these isolates from the environment
was pvo1 and interestingly
a lot of these isolates didn't share the
same plasmid
across different so we know that puvo1
is spreading or sorry kpc is spreading
at all levels via pvo1 by plasmid
by binary fission carrying the same
plasmid and by transposon
and even maybe a second transposon
moving all over the place
none of which we would have seen if we
just did short read sequencing
so to complete to finish you know it's
important to understand that
mobile genetic elements are moving genes
of drug resistance all around
i think this is probably happening all
the time in nature
and we just don't see it because we
don't have
that consequential of a gene
with a natural experiment where we were
tracking that specific gene over a long
period of time in the environment and in
patients
i think that long read sequencing if you
really want to understand the genetic
context for mobile genetic elements
long-range sequencing is critical
because as i've shown you can get really
tricked by the short read sequencing and
i think lastly wastewater
premise plumbing can make a great
reservoir for drug-resistant
gram-negative bacteria
of course there's loads and loads of
people that have worked on this and this
has taken years to put together
um but um a lot of people to thank
especially derrick crook anna shepard
and um heart of parikh who did the
the work on the plasmids at the drain
level
so thank you very much end of talk